avec nous claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous les générations futures
qui nous pardonneront pas si nous
échouons cette rave elle est signée
boris johnson inquiété très remonté
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
britannique
il faut dire que la coop présente des
enjeux importants pour son pays pour lui
même je crois qu'il aimerait bien avoir
un succès diplomatique c'est une réunion
en effet très importante avec beaucoup
nom de des hommes politiques mais aussi
les ong mais aussi des spécialistes et
il voudrait à un succès politique
franchement il aura un petit peu de mal
à avoir un succès politique parce que
l'objectif de cette coop 26 et d'essayer
de modifier de corriger la trajectoire
sur laquelle nous sommes curieux nous
emmener vers une limite d'une hausse de
température de 1 5% à l'échéance fixée
par la coop 21 à paris nous emmène plus
tôt vers le double en tout cas vers 2,7
ou 2,8
degrés à pourcentage pardon degrés est
évidemment pour éviter cela pour se
remettre sur la trajectoire de 1,5 degré
il faudrait que chaque participant
chaque état prenne des engagements très
forts et il ne semble pas que ce soit
vraiment le cas donc boris johnson va
avoir beaucoup de mal à obtenir ce
succès et bien sûr il a utilisé un
langage dramatique vous avez cité
certains de ses propos il a même il a
même cité
l'écologiste la jeune suédoise que l'on
voit surtout les sur toutes les
télévisions en disant pas de bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla c'est qu'elle dit c'est
ce qu'elle dit habituellement nous
voulons des décisions concrètes et qui
produisent des effets simplement je
pense que ça va être très difficile bien
même si la grande bretagne et les pays
européens sont prêts à annoncer des
efforts supplémentaires or justement pas
de blabla est-ce que ça concerne le
royaume-uni est ce que c'est un bonne
élève par rapport au reste du monde pour
le charbon oui pour l'hydrocarbure non
le charbon oui alors c'est assez
intéressant parce que dans le fond la
révolution industrielle a eu lieu au
départ au royaume uni avec le charbon la
machine à vapeur le charbon et le
royaume uni a réussi à
décarbonés son économie
il y a encore dix ans le charbon
représentaient 40% de la production
électrique est aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose comme 2 % et ce sera fini il y
aura plus de centrales à charbon pour
faire de l'électricité dans deux ans
donc c'est une réussite de ce point de
vue là mais en revanche le gouvernement
britannique continue de donner des
licences d'exploration pétrolière au
large les villes shetland dans kof shore
et ceci commence à déranger un peu
madame soeur jeunes c'est-à-dire la
cheffe du gouvernement écossais qui
considère que pour donner de nouvelles
licences de recherche d'hydrocarbures ou
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures a
fortiori il devrait consulter le
gouvernement écossais ce qu'il ne fait
pas en effet c'est de la compétence de
londres alors par ailleurs le nucléaire
représente environ 20% et des centrales
nucléaires sont en construction y
compris des centrales de technologie
français d'ailleurs donc
disons comparons ce qui est comparable
c'est-à-dire les pays de l' ocde des
pays développés et la grande-bretagne
royaume grand bretagne se situe
pratiquement au milieu des pays de l'
ocde dans le palmarès de la lutte contre
les émissions de co2 en tout cas le
gouvernement johnson qui la neutralité
carbone en 2050 également